what's up guys
bang bang it is lunch money time got
that monday energy well while she's
trying to get rich the rest of us just
trying to
get our money right i'm here with the
beautiful intelligent planet if i live a
marine over pompano
p-i-m-p don't forget that lunch but it's
not sponsored by block five but
if you remember last week i said block
five dot com slash pump
block five dot com slash pump and i said
can somebody make that into a song
well guess what what somebody did it uh
jason truman
jazz tree music on twitter at
j j a s t r e music
so we're gonna play it now
[Music]
you can go to blockclock.com
you can go to blockclock.com
[Music]
you can go to blockclock.com
all right that's an awesome song i love
it and if you don't like it i really
don't care but everyone should go to
blackfy.com
pomp what's up okay guys i just i have
to get this off my chest because
otherwise he's gonna tell you
this weekend was a crazy weekend
first of all i got like deathly sick for
one day i'm fine now
unclear if it's covered
no it was like a day and a half so okay
36 hours
i was i felt that like i was like
immobilized i could not move out of bed
i was just really tired
i wasn't coughing i wasn't sneezing i
was just tired took a covet test don't
have the results yet we'll let you know
but that happened then
well actually before i got sick we were
walking across the street
and my knee just gave out and i couldn't
walk for a second
then suddenly i have a
crown on my tooth my whole tooth came
out
she she's missing a tooth right now like
a north carolina hillbilly she's missing
the two yeah
one of the teeth is gone like his house
he's got a big old hole there yeah so he
was calling me a hillbilly all weekend
well if you are missing a tooth then
you're a hillbilly now i can't go until
i know if i have
it's just the whole situation but i am
here i am fine
what are the topics this is not coffee
time this is this is important
all right important time biden
plans immediate executive actions to
roll back
trump era after inauguration speech and
he's basically
he's basically planning to hit the
ground running with executive orders
there is scrapping the travel ban on
majority muslim countries was that still
going on
okay rejoining the paris agreement uh
and establishing a pastor's citizenship
for 11 million undocumented
undocumented immigrants what do you
think this is the beauty of democracy
is that one political party gets an
office they do everything that they want
to do
then they either get reelected or they
get
kicked out of office by being a
different political party being elected
and that political party then makes the
progress that they want to make
and so basically part of the checks and
balances of a multi-party system
is that there's constantly new party
coming in now the problem is that we
have a two-party system so
these two idiot parties just keep
fighting with each other
go go go on no go ahead well the problem
is you said checks and balances
the the uh normally what happens right
if i'm correct is if when a president
issues an executive order they can then
be blocked
right by uh depends but yeah oh it
depends right okay yeah
checks and balances is i think what
you're trying to say is that there's a
consolidated
government undivided in terms of they
have uh
democratic control of the entire stack
of the
housing senate of the executive and
legislation side but there's still other
checks and balances that obviously exist
with other bodies of government so the
president can't just go do whatever he
wants
the president and congress can't go do
whatever they want there are checks and
bounces but
the idea of democracy of constantly
there is every four years an election
and there can be progress rolled back
progress rolled back
ends up being a pretty good system like
we were talking yesterday
that's better than being in a country
where there is no
two-party system there is just one party
usually there's not even one party
usually there's just one family
okay all right next guys we are in miami
currently
miami mayor frit hey girl
oh my god he has been doing that all
weekend
um mayor francis suarez the mayor
of miami who is wonderful uh has been
chatting
what are you doing i'm just doing a
little advertising for my father pomp
boys motors if you have a nice classic
car and you would like that car to be
fixed
pond boys motors they'll hook you up the
best in the business
profile all right come on you don't get
advertising
okay my pops gets whatever he wants pomp
boys motors just google it
i don't know why that's so funny you cut
me off i was talking about mayor suarez
this morning at like 4am him at 3 58 am
to be exact
him and elon musk were chatting
and elon said cars and trucks stuck in
traffic generate mega tons of toxic
gases and particulate
but boring company road tunnels under
miami would solve traffic
and be an example to the world spoke
with ron
santis that's the governor of florida
about tunnels last week if governor and
mayor will
want this done will do it and mayor
suarez comes at him goes count me in
no brainer we would love to be the
prototype
city all right couple of things here one
why is he awake at 3 58
mayor suarez savage 4 a.m out here
grinding that's why he's going to win
you literally tweeted that
yeah 4 a.m that's exactly why he's going
to win because he's out here grinded
all your other mayors are sleeping while
your cities are all falling apart but
mayor suarez
nice work two elon musk is absolutely
going to build tunnels under all these
cities
i understand everyone is yelling
screaming oh he hasn't built any yet hey
yeah whatever
shut up stop shorting this guy this guy
literally has launched rockets
and then landed him back on drones in
the ocean he's built the best electric
vehicle car he's going to build a
goddamn tunnel all right so everyone
chill out
third i know all these people are
yelling and screaming like miami's got
water underneath it miami can't do
there's tunnels already so everyone
chill out okay
if this if they want to do it will get
done in terms of you need the governor
you need the mayor and you need a
freaking entrepreneur to do it
it looks like all three of them are
interested in doing it so everyone
relax and stop shorting innovation i'm
so tired of hearing everyone say well
you can't do this you can't do that
the ground you're not a scientist shut
up i'm pretty sure that elon musk
knows more about the freaking soil and
the land
and the water underneath the land and
whether they can build a tunnel or not
than you do
so get off your keyboard shut up and if
you want to go do something
go build your own tunnels but they're
going to do it so chill out
are we good i saw all these people being
oh elon musk is just looking for the
price coverage elon musk built the best
electric vehicle
in the world and on top of that is
launching rockets and landing them on
drone ships in the ocean and they're
still
idiots on the internet who are like oh
my gosh
jamie lynn spears britney spears's
sister is complaining saying that
a tesla kills cats because her cats
can't hear
the car coming and bad things happened
so anyway also yeah that's not real oh
it is real
she called him a cat killer that's just
another example why you shouldn't own
cats you should own dogs
dogs we need some more dogs i know some
of you all know that speech
i need dogs i need no kitty cats i need
some dogs
google it coastal carolina football
coach gave up all time did he have a
tooth
post game no he gave a post game
interview one time and they were asking
about whether people uh
like about us play or something i need
more dogs i don't need no kitty cats
i got you i got you china was the first
country to re
to report cases of kobe 19 but now the
chinese economy has returned to growth
by the second quarter last year powered
by strong manufacturing and export
activity
having a v shaped recovery
curve i don't believe it i don't really
really
but they also said the consumer spending
was soft
so i don't know look china absolutely
has done better dealing with the virus
uh in terms of all of a sudden they're
better they're having wet and wild
parties yeah
is like popping now uh so absolutely
there's
uh recovery happening i think the big
question though is just
uh you know how legitimate is the data
that's being reported
nobody really knows but uh i think it is
a good sign directionally and so we'll
see kind of are they actually
pre-pandemic levels or not i don't know
but they had a very
strong recovery whether they're fully
recovered or not is a whole other debate
okay can we not thank you my dad will be
happy if you guys go there
go ahead my and my mom goes there every
day she works there
i don't know who's employee of who but
they're both there
do you want to meet papa palm go ahead
by the way by the way hold on just so
we're clear you're laughing
but i'm not going to say who it is but i
know who it is
somebody who watches this show saw the
last time i wore this shirt
called on the phone from california i
believe it is and said hey
i have a car that i need to get fixed
and they shipped the car
to my father yes and my dad is fixing it
right now
so wait that's awesome
and now my dad thinks that all of a
sudden i'm
an advertiser for him and he keeps
telling me how i need to keep
advertising his business so
how come you never do that for the
profile well because you got enough
signups let's go
he got one customer relax
okay but a big one from california big
fish
okay uh president-elect joe biden
nominated gary genzler to serve as the
commissioner of the sec
and rohit chopra to lead the consumer
financial protection
bureau what do we think of these picks
gary ginsler is going to be amazing for
krypto i can't wait
jay clayton is not so amazing for crypto
wait why is he going to be amazing he
just understands he actually like taught
a course at mit i think or something
about like blockchain and crypto yeah
what
uh he's just very forward thinking he
really understands uh kind of the
promise of the technology
and he's basically a 180 degree
difference than jclean
all right a 70-foot rocket riding
beneath the wing of a retrofitted boeing
747
aircraft detached from the plane and
fired itself into earth's orbit on
sunday
making the first successful launch for
virgin orbit why are you laughing
because they literally took a 747 they
strapped a rocket on it and then they
flew in the air and they shot the rocket
off the 747 and it put nine
satellites in space so there you go that
is the most gangster thing i've heard in
ohio yeah it's like a little
it's like a big mama airplane and a tiny
baby rocket
airplane it's literally that's literally
what they did is they took a 747
they flew the plane in the air and they
had a rocket on the bottom of it
and then when they got close it fired
the rocket off the 747
rather than like firing a rocket at a
adversary country they fired that [ __ ]
into space
and it went into orbit it's awesome put
seven
nine nine satellites in space yeah it's
only a 70 foot rocket that's not really
that big
uh but it's still pretty big um and uh
it worked like who would have thought i
love this this is amazing
i fought it off y'all saw it was trying
to sneak up on me and i was like
he ain't getting me on that's that's how
he was showing me yesterday that he
fought off a virus because i was like
how come you're not sick if i'm
i don't get sick yeah okay now i looked
at the virus the virus looked at me
meaning your virus i not not cope with
just so we're all clear yeah uh whatever
she had it looked at me
i looked at it and i was like oh you
ain't coming over here uh-uh
and they said no i don't wanna mess with
that guy i didn't get sick
oh my god stop all right next anything
else
oh we got ask lunch money time hashtag
asklm in the comments i only
got one question for you guys today we
gotta step up these questions guys we
gotta step em up
uh for eight hours and 15 minutes last
night
just got a notification on my phone
you're in a weird mood today
okay go ahead just google it okay okay
got it we got it
okay it i'll make you guys a deal if you
guys
bring business to my dad at pomp boys
motors
i'll get on a facetime with you anybody
anybody who sees this and goes there
and uh and gives them business i you
tell my dad
and uh or my mom and they'll facetime me
and his mom
will my mom will track him down and make
sure he
facetimes you okay fsck
google asks hey question for you both in
a world where crypto was never invented
how would your portfolio look
you know how mine would look exactly how
it does now
wait yeah but no mine would be
one percent cash 99
those stupid little cardboard baseball
cards that are selling for five million
dollars that's how mine would look
i would sell all them cards i would get
millions of dollars
so why don't you go do that now because
i don't have that many cards
or millions of dollars oh okay
uh my would probably just be all early
stage startups
uh really i still wouldn't own any
public equities uh i wouldn't own any
bonds
i wouldn't own any shiny rocks or metals
i would just uh
no cardboard cards no i don't underst i
it's not that i don't understand it is
that i know i don't have an advantage
there
and therefore like some of the people
that i know
are the biggest investors in that space
and their
their advantage and their information
asymmetry is so much greater than mine
that i don't even go play in that space
like i'm just going to focus on the
things that i know that i've got an
advantage on
so i would just focus on early stage
investing which basically what i do now
anyways so
i just do what i'm doing cool chill
thank you guys see you tomorrow
all right guys remember pop boys motors
and the north carolina
kill billy with a missing tooth see you
guys tomorrow
bang bang hope you guys enjoyed this
episode of lunch money as much as we did
and don't forget lunch money is now
sponsored by block five
so go check them out there's a link in
the description that you can click on
i'm an investor
a user and a huge fan
what you're a bigger fan of block fight
than you are of me
block lies my second favorite thing in
the world behind polena they've got
three products
they can give you a us dollar loan you
can earn up to 8.6
interest on an interest-bearing account
or you can buy and sell cryptocurrencies
on their crypto exchange
i personally use the interest bearing
account there's not very many places
where you'll find
up to eight point six percent interest
on a deposit in an interest bearing
account
go do your own research there's risk
associated but 8.6
is pretty compelling so click on the
link in the description say thanks to
the folks at blockfly
subscribe to our channel like the video
annoy pulling in the comments
and we'll see you guys tomorrow and be
kind to your friends